[Music]
gavin is with us gavin's in chicago hey
gavin what's up
hey james thanks for having me sure
what's up
i wanted to ask you a question can i
afford to go to hawaii with my wife for
a friend's wedding
what do you have the money
i i think we do she's worried we've
never spent this much money
um do you have the money in cash without
going into debt to do it is what i'm
asking oh that's absolutely yeah we're
at four five six okay
you're in baby steps four five and six
and how much is the trip
yeah we're thinking like seven grand
yeah sounds about right
and you've got that money and what do
you guys make a year
we make about 180 000 a year why could
you not afford this
because we're so cheap
[Laughter]
now the truth comes out
it has nothing to do with the arithmetic
it's the emotional state
yeah i mean we're trying we're trying to
pay off trying to pay off our houses
yeah and
and and you know live like no one else
and yeah
how old are you guys
i'm 39 you ever been to you ever been to
hawaii
i have on a company trip so i never paid
for it has she been
yes she has she has she said she has no
desire but we we haven't been to kauai
yet we've been to the big island and not
quite okay but you're not just going to
fly over for the wedding and then bolt
as soon as the reception's over correct
oh no no that's all yeah that's a that's
a 12 hour flight we're gonna go for a
week hold on there you go first my point
is that's the chair
you guys got to talk about this as an
awesome opportunity to get away and
reward each other for this sacrifice you
make really good money you're out of
debt except you're home you're executing
a financial plan four five six
um you should go
yeah thank you you should do this you
should do well guess what she said if
you said yes then we get to go okay
i'm not i'm i'm not making the decision
but i'm just saying
the arithmetic is that you you are not
being irresponsible
okay and when you said we're just cheap
and you laughed you were sort of kidding
but not really
and so the thing you guys want to be
careful of
there are three things you can do with
money you can invest it you can be
generous with it and you can enjoy it
almost everyone is weak in one of them
and so watch the one that you're weak in
and you're the one you guys are weak in
is you're not you're not good at
enjoying your money
right and you need to you know i mean we
have a we have a million dollars in our
nest egg yeah so you need to so you're
really good at investing how's your
generosity probably medium
minimal yeah i'll see
the truth is there's usually a
correlation between uh
the people who enjoy their money and the
generosity so one of the things we do at
our house and this might help you
is um you kind of feel like you're doing
something wrong if you're doing
something opulent like a week long in
hawaii that's a big time expenditure
right so one of the things we do is
sometimes we'll just increase our
generosity by the same amount we spend
on ourselves
okay and we just like uh okay god who
can we who do you want to help today uh
i want to give seven thousand dollars to
uh i wanna buy two single moms a three
thousand 000 car this week show me lead
them to me lord and and then i'll go do
that and and then i'll go to hawaii and
i don't think about it yeah
gotcha sometimes the generosity muscle
works almost simultaneously with the
enjoyment muscle take some extra cash to
hawaii and bless somebody out of their
mind who's serving take 70 000 and buy
you a truck while you're there
call beverly pick her up on the way
drop a truck off of boise on your way